[Applaudissements]
tu me prendre la tension ascenseur à ce
que j'avais dit ascenseur moi tout un
choc aux moins bonne c'est que vous avez
déjà dit en premier à son sens moral on
va faire un personnage quelqu'un gvt et
des ascenseurs au début non croyez que
ces déçus qui disait ascenseur qui
avaient la chance non non ça se passera
ce que je voulais dire en premier
ascenseur vous avez dit quoi en premier
tadic j'ai des ascenseurs aussi a reçu
l'année à quel moment
parce que quand il a dit qu'il veut
rendre l'ascenseur g10 ascenseur ou à
cga moi quoi combat l'ascenseur
ascenseur tous les deux oui cette fesci
bloque pas du tout pas du tout on va
vous débloquez en faisant cette épreuve
d'ascenseur qui a fait qu'approuver
preuve entre 2 et ses preuves en
indochine
excuse moi tu as une gastro parce que tu
as
elle
et oui et oui le petit sac à gastro on
va perdre cette épreuve d'ascenseur qui
a fait ses preuves danseur en indochine
cette option le retourne tout vous allez
faire affaire faille ciseaux la musique
du pays derrière le dos excellence vous
dirais bien sûr ce fameux mot chez full
ou mairie qui vient du danois qui veut
dire steve au soccer chez vous mais
attention pierre feuille ciseaux n'ya
pas depuis celui qui fait d'eux le puits
air feuille ciseaux celui qui gagne
pourra choisir où l'ascenseur d'accord
ok les escaliers ascenseurs sur son sort
il n'est ni dans un instant c'est pour
ça ça me rappelle la naissance et tous
attendent ils aux associés
oui j'ai vomi
j'ai vomi chifoumi le givre ou
ascenseurs
oui
jonathan quelque chose que je ne ferai
jamais à l'ascenseur à son look avons
gagné tu maîtrises pas tomber j'ai rien
à faire dans ce défi j'ai fait mes
preuves les gars j'en ai pris d'étape
dans là joker ou [ __ ] on a touché un
truc sensible apparemment il n'est pas
né dans un il a été pêché ça comme ça je
remette tous les notables sancerre a
quand même